can you hear me yes i can hear myself welcome
welcome to tonight's um sfi community lecture
uh this will feature our colleague stuart
feinstein uh my name is david krakow and the
president of the center for institute um and i
wanted to thank the mckinnon family foundation
for supporting this making these events free
and also supported by the lensic performing arts
center and the santa fe reporter so thank you
all of you for allowing us to make these events
available so um stuart is a fractal faculty member
fractal faculty at the santa fe institute is our
most distinguished visiting professorship it's
uh you know it's a bit whimsical stewart is the
former chair of the department of biology at
columbia and runs a lab on the olfactory system
and stewart is a sort of perfect art science
mind because before stuart was a scientist he was
actually a director in theater he spent the first
i don't know how long he did it but certainly he
didn't start science until he was about 30 and
so spent 15 to 20 years directing plays in new
york and san francisco so he told me he's going to
dance tonight before he gives his tour businesses
so he then went to yale did his phd ended up
at columbia where he's a professor as i said
he's also a fellow of the aaas and on and
on guggenheim fellow and that sort of thing
which sort of demonstrates that a career in
science doesn't have to follow a direct path that
you can take these oblique turns and probably
end up a more creative mind as a consequence
and stewart came to our attention at sfi because
of the books he wrote um he wrote one book on
ignorance that was published in 2012 and another
book in on failure that was published in 2015
so we thought who would be better to have at a
science institute than somebody's written a book
on ignorance and failure uh and so we reached out
to him said come to the sound events you and then
to our enormous chagrin he told us that while
at sfi he wanted to write a book on optimism
which somehow was in violation
of the implicit contract but
stewart manages to be very pessimistic
about optimism so it's sort of somehow
it's all fine so um so with no further ado i will
turn it over to our friend and colleague stuart
all right let's see if we can get through this now
uh ignorance failure uncertainty looks awful um
but i'm going to try and uh try and redefine
some of these words for us tonight i'm going
to talk about each of these four words and i'm
going to try and redefine them because each of
them has picked up over the years picked up and
lost many layers of meaning and usage and have
in many ways trivialized these words in some cases
especially from the viewpoint of science where i
think they're extremely important ideas and um
and are not particularly well understood maybe
so i'm going to use these four words and i'm
going to try and complicate them actually uh
because i think that's what they need to be and
after all this is a sfi event and so simplifying
them would sort of seem not to be in the spirit
of the thing right so so i'm going to complicate
them or i'm going to attempt to complicate them
i'm going to begin with optimism because um
well because it's the most important of the words
to me and i'm going to start with optimism and
then go back to the other three and sort of circle
around and hope to connect them back to optimism
in the end if you think that sounds improbable
you're probably right but we'll give it a try
so so the thing about optimism is that um we all
have an idea of what what the word means and what
we think it means what we mean by it but actually
um when one looks into it it's not so clear
for one i've always felt that optimism was an
important part of science all the scientists i
know are pretty optimistic people by which i don't
mean cheerful or you know happy or anything like
that i mean most of them are they're pretty cranky
people in general or many of them certainly are
but nonetheless i consider them optimists they
come in every morning and try and experiment
they have a question to ask their grants may
get rejected their papers turned down and all
the rest of that but they're there every morning
asking a question even though they know that 99
of the time they're likely to fail maybe they'll
get an answer maybe on a really good day they'll
get a better question but so i think they
have a very optimistic view of it and yet
for all the books both scholarly and and for
the public kind of thing that have been written
about science and the process of science you
virtually never see the word optimism mentioned
it's not in any indexes except for one book
that i know of where the word optimism appears
about science but otherwise you never see it
so i thought i should look into this and so i
did start looking into it and one of the things i
found was that contrary to what i thought and what
i'm guessing most of you think optimism is not a
particularly old idea it's actually a relatively
new idea or at least the word is new the word
optimism was actually invented as invented in
1759 it didn't exist before that it was
invented let me see if this works i hope
yes it was invented by voltaire for his novel his
satirical novel candide um and that was written
in response to um his archrival gottfried
leibniz who had published earlier a book
in which he claimed just by pure logic that the
world we live in must be the best of all possible
worlds his logic being that if you believe that
the world was created by an all-powerful creator
then why would that creator do anything but create
the best of all possible worlds so even if it's
full of misery and war and crime and disease and
all the rest of that awful stuff it still would
be worse without all that in some cockamamie
way i guess in any case that was the idea um
and voltaire of course found this ridiculous
and so he wrote this satire called candide or
optimism and that is actually the first use of
the word livenets use the word optimus to mean
best or optimum that was kind of the latin root
and but but that root only refers to things or
situations as being the best possible case of it
not to an outlook or a mood or anything like that
i will say however that neither of these
definitions these early definitions of optimism
are the kind of optimism i'd like to talk about
so in the case of of leibniz we're really kind
of talking about something closer to what
i would call resignation i mean this is the
best it's going to be so you know live with it um
that's it and and voltaire's candide really was
a kind of a naive gullibility sort of optimism
in which candide suffers all sorts of horrible
events and and professor pangloss claims
that they're all just wonderful you know as
a satire of course and so um i mean so it took
on this meaning of sort of a naive gullibility
so so those are the two earliest versions of of
the word optimism and what it means now we have
some other common or contemporary uses but i don't
mean any of these either i don't mean cheerfulness
i don't mean positive thinking or mindfulness
or glasses that are half full or whichever it
is that they are i don't mean any of those things
and i also don't mean this sort of other common
idea that that's become current in evolutionary
psychology that optimism has sort of been baked
into our brains by thousands or millions of
years of evolution hundreds of thousands of
years of evolution as some sort of a i don't
know some sort of a bias or claim or a mechanism
for us to deal with death and all these other
terrible things that happen to us and so forth
in any case i don't think there's really much
good evidence for that either and even if there
is it's not the optimism that i mean i'd rather
talk about what i would call scientific optimism
and i use this phrase that i think for me
characterizes what i mean by scientific optimism
and that is that we as a generation we as a group
unlike virtually anybody more than 100 years ago
are able to say about things it could be otherwise
it needn't be as it is it could be otherwise there
is possibility there is progress progress
doesn't always work out for the best but on
balance it generally does i mean yes we hate
the bomb but we do like anesthesia god knows
and so um and so that's not something that was
easily said by previous generations by most of
our ancestors for whom they were born grew
up and died in virtually the same technology
and for whom they mostly did what their parents
would do and their children would do what they
did the records of medieval and late medieval
even early modern europe show that people never
strayed more than about five miles from the place
they were born unless they were conscripted into
an army or something and since some were awful so
this notion of it could be otherwise is something
actually kind of new for us if you think about
it so i'm even tempted you can tell me whether
you like this idea or not at the end to coin
a new word because we have the word optimistic
and we have the word optimistically so
you could add two letters to optimistic
to optimistic or you could subtract two letters
from optimistically and come up with the word
optimistical which seems like it should be a word
right i mean it fits right in there doesn't it
but but it's not a word it's not in the dictionary
you can't use it in scrabble except oddly enough
in the uk where it's okay for scrabble but
what do they know about english so you know
so so i'm going to use this word optimistical
and by optimistically means something that
is not a psychological disposition but
rather a philosophical outlook outlook
an outlook that includes such things as but is
not necessarily limited to a kind of a blend
of hubris and humility which i think is very
specific and special to science the hubris of
believing we can know how this place works we
can know a great deal about how it works and
yet the humility of facing how much we don't know
about it all how much mystery still remains the
notions of progress and possibility as i mentioned
earlier and and a notion of awe and and what one
scientist said to me about being a scientist
was the ability to experience the sublime
so all in sublimity that that what's out there is
just so remarkable and we have some purchase on it
so that's kind of what i'm trying to say by
optimistical so where does this come from how
is this related to science so i have to take a
short sort of historical thing here and this is
going to be a bit of a potted history because
who has the time to go through the whole thing
um but i'm going to start with francis
bacon and the beginnings of what i would say
when science began to become what we today call
modern science in sort of late 16th century europe
and what has now spread to become a kind of
a global activity but that's kind of where
it started in a very chaotic place 16th
century europe was a real mess i have to
tell you i mean plagues wars um famine droughts
weather terrible weather conditions of all sorts
of the 15th century had the highest homicide
rate on record although we're pushing it i
suspect right now but but that's the had the
highest homicide rate on record and anyway uh
francis bacon then published this book called nova
morganim or the new instrument the new method as
it were in 1620 in which he proposed this whole
new way of thinking about science and in which
a series of ideas that each one of which in itself
may not have been brand new but the coalescence of
these ideas i think was novel and new and created
what i would call the scientific revolution what
many people call the scientific revolution but
which many philosophers of science and historians
of science prefer not to use that term but i use
it because it's easier this is the frontispiece
from bacon's book and those are the pillars of
hercules at the at the end of the the edge of
the mediterranean um and the the original caption
for that was neptus ultra which is go no further
because the mediterranean was considered well it
means the center of the world right mediterranean
means center of the world and it was considered
all there was and one wouldn't venture out past it
but then of course the age of discovery and all
the rest of that and so the plus ultra was turned
into a plus ultra go further go further and that's
the idea of these ships passing then through the
gates of hercules to discover new things so the
main thing i would say that bacon proposed was a
renunciation of authority that we would no longer
get our knowledge from aristotle from the state
or from the church so buried somewhere in this
book is a phrase that i think is really important
in which he says i'm slightly paraphrasing
it but which he basically says previously
truth came from authority henceforth authority
will come from truth now think about that for
a moment that's a really big idea in a few words
that's really a what a sea change a seismic change
a paradigm shift whatever you want to call those
sorts of things this was a really very new idea
so the notion was that knowledge would now
come from experiments and i should point out
that the idea of experiments is also new in the
sense that bacon actually is now considered the
father of experimental science because he was
the one who dreamt up the idea of an experiment
which is different from experience or trial and
error the notion of an experiment is to take some
slice of nature and remove it from its normal
context and poke it and prod it and do things
to it hold everything else equal if it as it were
and and bacon even said torture it if need be to
get its secrets to learn the secrets of nature and
then believe that you could put this back into its
context and know something and remarkably this
sort of works a lot of the time not all the time
but it works a lot of the time bacon
himself by the way never did an experiment
but famously he did one experiment and died from
it which which is kind of ironic i suppose he um
the story goes in any case that he was on his
way from town with a companion um to some manor
house out in the country and they were having a
discussion along the way and uh bacon hypothesized
that you could preserve meat by freezing it or
cooling it down and freezing it and that he had
an idea for an experiment so they stopped at
the next farmhouse and bought a chicken from
what was presumably a bewildered peasant couple
and immediately killed the chicken eviscerated
it and stuffed it with snow it was all over the
ground in the process of which bacon apparently
soaked his boots and his pants up to i don't
know where or whatever and then they rode onto
the manor by the time they got to the manor house
bacon had caught a terrible cold a week later it
turned into pneumonia and a week later he was
dead the chicken i don't know about actually i
have to say but you can imagine so that was the
only experiment the poor guy ever did but anyway
his notion was that we would have experiments so
the first thing that science does in the baconian
method is to create ignorance a tremendous amount
of ignorance because all the knowledge before had
been from aristotle the start of the state of the
church and that was no longer going to suffice so
the first thing science really does is create
ignorance and i would say that that's still
true that this is still the basis of an awful lot
of what we do in science it's not the production
of facts although we may do that as well but
rather the continued creation of ignorance
not just any ignorance there's all kinds of
ignorances low quality ignorance is high quality
ignorance and it makes a difference which you do
so let me talk now a little bit about ignorance
let me first i suppose trying to disabuse
you of some ideas about science that are
sort of common which you may or may not hold
or some of you may or may not hold one is that
we're patiently putting pieces into a puzzle
and the idea here though is that one day
we could finish this puzzle but i don't
think that's the case of science i mean
you know with puzzles the manufacturer has
sort of guaranteed that there's a solution
that's kind of not really true with the
universe it seems to me we have no guarantee
that we'll just keep putting pieces in and
come to a solution nor do i think it's like
peeling you know the the layers off of an onion
to get to some central fundamental truth and
then that'll be the end of it we'll understand
it all from there nor is it like the the famous
sort of iceberg idea that we only see 10 of it
because you could see the rest of it you could
learn about the whole iceberg it's there and and
it's approachable assuming it doesn't melt first
these days so i think science is more like this
image i suppose there are ripples on a pond where
if you think of knowledge as being inside those
ripples and increasing as that knowledge increases
then so does the circumference of what's in touch
with the ignorance and so as we increase knowledge
we also increase ignorance we increase the amount
of ignorance that we're in touch with especially
in these days when facts are pretty easy to come
by with google and wikipedia and whoever else is
out there or will be out there it's really much
more important for us to be around the edge of
these ripples to be around the edge not in
the middle where all the questions are so
i think it's common for us to think that
we begin in ignorance we begin not knowing
something and we either go to school or do
experiments or read books or something like that
and we gain some knowledge but then what do we
do with that knowledge because that's really
the critical issue so i'd like to turn that
sort of arrow around and say really it's knowledge
that leads to ignorance and again not just any
ignorance but better ignorance maybe you prefer
to think of it as questions so what we do with
knowledge is to frame better or more sophisticated
deeper questions this is um ii robbie
famous physicist won a nobel prize in 1944 for his
discovery and work on nuclear magnetic resonance
still used today in chemistry labs very
important instrument and which turned into
mri or magnetic resonance imaging which is as you
well know a very important medical diagnostic tool
robbie was a professor of physics at columbia
but before my time if you can believe that
um but but from members of the physics department
i'm told that one of his favorite stories to
tell about was when he was a young i think it's
important to say a young immigrant boy growing
up on the lower east side of new york when he
and his friends would come home from school
their mothers would ask them so what did you
learn in school today but mrs robbie always
said so isidore did you ask any good questions
today i think mrs robbie had it right and and ii
always claimed that this is why he was a scientist
and this is why he was able to do science because
he thought about questions not about what he
knew but about what he didn't know so how do
we go about this search for better ignorance i'm
going to use a phrase called negative capability
this may sound a bit oxymoronic it was actually
devised by the dreamy eyed poet john keats in
a letter to his brother in which he defined
the term negative capability as when a man
maybe they would say a person is capable of
being in uncertainties mysteries and doubts
without any irritable reaching after fact and
reason and he considered this to be the ideal
creative state of mind for the literary mind and
i think it's true for the scientific or any other
mind it's the ideal creative state this notion
of being patient with ignorance being patient
with mystery letting it sit with you without
being irritable and you can reach after fact and
reason as we do but not irritably this was sort
of stated in a similar way by a famous physicist
erwin schroedinger in which he said in an honest
search for knowledge you quite often have to abide
by ignorance for an indefinite period and i
think he would know that quite personally so
all right so so ignorance is important obviously
science is about what we don't know it's more
important to think about what we don't know to
phrase good questions so you'll go with me that
scientists about the unknown i hope all right
but what about what about the deeper ignorance
the perilous unknown unknown if you will so you
know the unknown unknown that what we don't know
we don't know is a phrase that many of you will
recognize as having been uttered by the infamous
d h rumsfeld the secretary of defense during the
period of our somewhat misbegotten adventures in
in iraq and uh and afghanistan and during a senate
hearing he claimed that yes there were many things
that we didn't know there were a lot of unknowns
and things like that um but more importantly and
what really led to the the screw-ups were all the
unknown unknowns the things that the the ones we
didn't know we didn't know now he was somewhat
ridiculed for this was actually not not a stupid
thing to say it's rather clever and i'm happy to
say he's not the first person to have said it took
me a while to find this but um i'm sure it's been
around for a while but the first written record of
it that i've been able to locate actually was by
another dh d h lawrence who wrote a poem in 1917
called new heaven and earth rather long narrative
piece about the transition from this life to the
next from this plane to another plane and towards
the end there's a stanza that goes now here was i
new awakened and with my hands stretching out and
touching the unknown the real unknown the unknown
unknown and so this was to my knowledge the first
mention of it i haven't been able to find it
anywhere else and he doesn't cite anything about
it but anyway this is the unknown unknown the real
unknown how do we get to this how do we figure out
what we don't know we don't know i mean this is a
tricky business so i'm going to suggest to you now
that we move to the second word because the way we
do this is by failing that failure is our portal
into the unknown unknown you do an experiment
because you don't know something it doesn't work
or you get a result you didn't expect so now
you know there was something you didn't know you
didn't know that you have to go back and sort of
work on right this is a quote from ben franklin
i have a bunch of quotes scattered throughout
this i'm not trying to be fancy about
it or anything i just think if somebody
said something useful they shouldn't be left out
of the conversation just because they're dead
so so i use these and also i think it's important
to note that that this is a conversation that's
been going on for some time and that our job is to
get into it and leave something behind as well but
but we should just join an ongoing conversation so
franklin arguably america's first scientist really
says perhaps the history of errors or failures of
mankind all things considered is more valuable and
interesting than that of their discoveries because
the truth after all is narrow and uniform but our
there's a gazillion ways you can screw up
right so it's much more interesting of course
um so there are some there are some ideas about
failure that are around two that are very common
and i'm going to try and go through those because
i don't mean any of those either just like i
didn't mean about optimism or or ignorance so one
of the famous quotes about failure is success is
learning to fail again and again with no lack
of enthusiasm it's often attributed to winston
churchill but there's no actual evidence he ever
said it uh he gets a lot of things attributed to
him fail hard fell fast is a favorite thing in
the tech industry these days i've discovered 10
000 ways that don't work edison actually did say
that about the light bulb which i always thought
was sort of funny because we use the light bulb
it's like click i got an idea but he claimed he
found ten thousand ways that didn't work first
failure is the opportunity to begin again more
intelligently okay this is i actually got this
in a fortune cookie at a chinese restaurant
failure was an opportunity in disguise and then
this quote if you're 40 years old and never had
a failure you've been deprived that was said by
the actress gloria swanson i don't actually know
what that means but it's very intriguing isn't it
i must say anyway i don't mean any of these things
this is none of the things that i mean about
failure i'm going to instead use the rather
enigmatic gertrude stein to define failure and
she said a real failure does not need an excuse
it is an end in itself think about that a failure
that is an end in itself so this is a different
way of thinking about failure failure is not
valuable to us retrospectively because it resulted
in some eventual success or led to an unexpected
serendipitous discovery i mean those are all
fine excuse me but but they're not a
requirement i think for failure to be valuable
failure is integral to the process of
science it can't be left out or avoided
it can be utilized and it can be improved i
like to think of failure and success not as
two sides of a coin but rather sort of two
horses pulling a wagon in the same direction
with a different value for each of them
similarly i guess the equally enigmatic samuel
beckett famously said in one of his later novels
ever tried ever failed no matter try again
fail again and that sounds like sort of this
old trope you know just keep trying and you'll get
there eventually but then at the end of it he has
failed better not interesting the
idea of learning how to fail better
so if we think failure is valuable if you go
along with me that far it's reasonable to ask
a couple of questions about it one would be
how much failure much failure is acceptable
presumably not 100 you don't want to fail all
the time but i think we seriously underestimate
the amount of failure that's acceptable so i'll
give it one of many examples i could give but
one from nature these are nature's top predators
they're evolutions you know they're the top of the
ladder as it were they are the kings or queens of
their various niches uh whether it's the air the
land the sea whatever and i'm sure you suspect as
as i did for a long time that um anytime they get
a little hungry they can just go out and bag
some snack but actually that's not the case if
you delve into the predator prey literature very
interesting literature by the way you find that
these these top predators are actually successful
on fewer than 25 of their attempts so they operate
at a failure rate of about 75 percent 75
of the time they don't get anything to eat
and so but they make a pretty good living at a
75 failure rate so again i think we underestimate
the amount of failure that's acceptable that's
actually valuable and that we should court we
should embrace i'm sorry this is the obligatory
new yorker cartoon i have to put it in here but
i'm not really sure there's anything that
would make golf more fun personally but
but and this looks pretty good to me but i think
it's true that we do this with all of our sports
right we intentionally make them difficult so
that failure is the most common thing that happens
because of course that makes the success more
credible another important part of failure i
mean would you trust a science that hit a hole
hole-in-one with every experiment we shouldn't
of course we don't have infallibility in science
that's another place that does infallibility so
another question we could legitimately ask i think
is how big a failure is acceptable well let's
go for a debacle why not right the whole thing
here right so its current usage of course is an
unmitigated disaster a total failure a catastrophe
but actually the etymology of the word debacle
the you know i never know whether it's debical or
debacle debacle i think is from the french debacle
which is not used so much anymore apparently but
it means to free or to unbar to unleash it was
originally used in the context of breaking up ice
of ice breaking so that is the idea of breaking
up something solid to create a new pathway that
sounds interesting doesn't it so i when we talk
about creativity for example we think that it
often arises from associating new ideas together
but i would say that often and sometimes more
powerfully creativity creative thinking new ideas
comes rather from dissociating ideas and things
that have been too long associated this is echoed
in the spanish philosopher ortega who said it
costs more to dissociate ideas than to associate
them and so and we use the word today breakthrough
to mean something important an important discovery
and so once again i think you can have a
pretty big failure one of the remarkable
things about science is that it has learned
how to fail non-catastrophically that failure
is not the end in fact it's usually a way
to get moving away to get on with things
all right so let me leave you with these two
key ideas about ignorance and failure and get
onto the tough one uncertainty so for ignorance
i think negative capability is an important idea
the capability the capacity to remain in doubt
and uncertainty to have patience with mystery
and ignorance and patience is very underrated
in this area and then with failure the idea from
stein and beckett that it's an end in itself that
uh it should be valued as integral to the process
and that one can in fact learn to fail better and
that this is really what one ought to learn to do
when being trained as a scientist or in my opinion
probably other places too but i know science
okay so we've got ignorance we've got failure
all right now we have to deal with uncertainty
so uncertainty also has some everyday meanings
that are different i think from their scientific
meanings let's talk about those for just a moment
i mean of course we all we all feel i think that
we live in very uncertain times and to a great
extent we do but but i suspect that human beings
have almost always felt this way in almost any day
and age i mean yes it's pretty uncertain around
here today but you know used to be a lot worse
because you used to have to deal with stuff like
this and you know they were usually camouflaged
so you didn't even see it coming when it came
and so the kind of uncertainty we deal with today
is i think quite a bit different than what some of
our ancestors had to deal with nonetheless we
enjoy uncertainty in many ways we we actually
engage with uncertainty so um when it comes
to gaming or sporting events or even mortality
we like to be uncertain about things i mean does
anybody in here really want to know the exact time
and date of their death or would you admit it if
you did i hope you don't i think we'd rather not
know these things we'd rather be uncertain about
these things um we even have this thing called the
spoiler alert right so that you know should you
be in the wrong time zone for a sporting event you
you're hidden the score is hidden from you so it
won't ruin your enjoyment of the game because if
you knew the outcome what good would it be um
but this is a different kind of uncertainty i
think than science because in this case these will
all finally resolve to some known state i mean the
hand is shown the bet is either won or lost the
game is score of the game is recorded somewhere
and i'm sorry to say that eventually there will
be your name and the time and date of your death
on a certificate somewhere um this is somewhat
different than i think what we have with science
um which i'll get into in just a moment so so we
think we have a problem with uncertainty and that
certainty is a great value and this is really what
science trafficked in for many years this notion
of well we can predict things we can know about
things we may even be able to govern some things
to some extent but i would say the problem we have
is actually with certainty and we should rather
value uncertainty so from the time of bacon
through about the middle of the 19th century or
so at least and really to some extent even today
still science has been driven towards ideas of
certainty towards an idealization of certainty
and eventually began to devise if you will or
or what the right word would be began to build
this this universe that was very deterministic
highly deterministic in which you could just
follow the laws of physics or chemistry or
geology kinetics things like that and you
could you would know what was going on it
was a clockwork kind of universe i guess this was
most cogently or most famously said in a phrase
from uh pierre laplace the french polymath
and mathematician intellect who said that some
intellect at some moment knew all the forces of
nature in motion all the positions of everything
around and so forth and if this intellect were
also vast enough to submit these data to analysis
it could embrace in a single formula the movements
of the greatest bodies out in space and down
to the tiniest atoms and for such an intellect
nothing would be uncertain and the future just
like the past would be present before its eyes
and so this is a totally deterministic world view
it's kind of depressing when you get to think
of it however i mean for to begin with this was
kind of optimistic progress and all the rest
of that but but scientific determinism leads i
think finally down a blind alley for us certainty
replaces possibility we can no longer say it could
be otherwise it could not be otherwise in fact
it will be exactly as it is planned out to be
from the big bang or the creation the moment
of creation whatever it was it's all been set
i think hubris uh and humility which need to be
in balance and science become out of balance and
hubris kind of takes over it's a very successful
technologically speaking kind of strategy
but it but it leaves us with a somewhat
degraded view of nature of a clockwork universe
and then we even begin to see people trying to
include human behavior and things of that nature
in social behavior and so forth in this idea of
a clockwork universe something deterministic and
based on formulas indeed i could say the worst
ills of of science during the enlightenment for
example were just this sort of idea eugenics
planned utopian societies illiberalism of
various sorts autocracies and so forth
that all came from the idea of applying
newtonian physics as it were or the idea of
newtonian physics to human behavior and human
human societies so although it was
successful at bringing a great deal
of order to the chaos of of medieval
europe and even early modern europe
what's the cost here what's the cost of of this
sort of determinism and this sort of certainty
i think it costs us that the deeper optimism of
possibility of free will maybe even art humor
psychiatry now recognizes certainty as a symptom
of depression so you might find that odd you think
well uncertainty because anxiety and worry and
all the rest of this but in point of fact people
who are definitely certain find that there's
really no reason to do much as it were right
the world is going to be what it's going to be
it's already set there's nothing i can do and that
loss of agency leads in fact to depression is now
considered as i say a major symptom of depression
so what's the alternative to determine is
unfortunately we were given an alternative
to determinism i would even call it a second
scientific revolution that i believe was
ushered in by charles darwin and simultaneously i
suppose by alfred wallace although we know called
it darwinian evolution and so um eponymously
it's charles darwin who um who i think is uh
unquestionably of course the father of modern
biology and his place in biology is unquestioned
and so forth but i actually believe that he had
a greater effect in many ways that darwinian
evolution the concept of it had a greater effect
on science in general even than it did in biology
because darwin and wallace showed that for the
first time you could you could obtain high degrees
of complexity and organization from an irreducibly
random process from something irreducibly random
connected to a feedback loop which he called
natural selection not having the word feedback
at his disposal at that time so this is a
remarkable idea right that that from pure
randomness from irreducible randomness you can
nonetheless obtain organization and complexity
there was of course as we all know a great deal
of pushback with darwin and we believe i think
that most of it was religious and so forth
and so on but that's not actually the case
um he didn't get that much push back from religion
until actually it got to america in 1925 in the
famous scopes trial when all of a sudden that came
up but but um unless you're a literal you know a
literal biblical reader of the old testament
which most of england wasn't in those days
it really wasn't a problem i mean darwin was
a well-known agnostic but you could continue
to believe in god and evolution and it was not a
not really a problem indeed darwin is buried in
westminster chapel and and wallace um maintained
a strong connection to variety of mystical and
mystical christian sex throughout his entire life
so it really wasn't religious the real pushback
came from scientists many from biologists who
may have been a little jealous or this or that
but also had different ideas about how evolution
might happen how species might originate but but
more importantly i think in physics and and the
harder sciences so um herschel john herschel a
famous astronomer at the time um disparagingly
called evolution the law of higgledy piggledy
which ironically turns out to be an absolutely
great description of evolution by the way so you
should keep that in mind um uh william jewell
cambridge don and well-known scientist and
theologian of the time who was actually the
president of british association of science
was dead set against evolution he felt that
it removed teleology or purpose from the world
that the world had become purposeless if it was
all from from random irreducibly random events
and that was unacceptable lord kelvin famous
physicist believed that evolution was impossible
because he had aged the earth at about 200 to
400 000 years old not enough time for evolution
because he turned out to be wrong by about four
or five orders of magnitude but at the time
he felt that evolution would be
impossible uh even fred hoyle a sort of
modern astronomer 20th century astronomer
of somewhat strange reputation um called uh
uh compared evolution to as if a tornado had
ripped through a junkyard and assembled a 747
that it was that improbable so this was the
this was the reaction of much of the scientific
community because it went against so definitely
against this deterministic view of the world
but there were a couple of holdouts in particular
ludwig boltzmann for me are kind of a personal
hero in physics who came up with a great deal
of thermodynamics and in particular statistical
mechanics who recognized that you could never know
the place of every atom in a container or whatever
but you could know something about the average
velocity that they were traveling out from the
temperature that you could measure and so you
wouldn't be able to place each item and where
it went and how it was going and how it would
work because that was utterly random but but
the average could be measured and so and in
fact in an interesting lecture that he gave um
boltzmann said the 19th century he thought should
be considered the century of darwin and he himself
felt that he'd like to be remembered as the darwin
of physics which he's not but he'd have my vote um
and then following fast on boltzmann of course
for people like maxwell einstein relativity boar
heisenberg and schroedinger the quantum world
complexity chaos sfi zone murray gelman even
kurt gerdel and mathematics the queen of the
sciences showed that fundamentally there were
undecidability issues in in mathematics and so
uncertainty becomes now uncertainty and randomness
now becomes sort of the key issue in science the
underlying part of science and i think even darwin
had this sense he understood this tension even
when he wrote it this is the last sentence from
the origin of species in which he says there
is grandeur in this view of life with its
several powers having been originally breathed
into a few forms into one or into one and that
whilst this planet has gone cycling on according
to the fixed law of gravity from so simple the
beginning endless forms most beautiful
and most wonderful have been in our being
evolved and so these two things are in tension but
they work together there is yes the predictability
within a limited sphere of how the planets
will move how gravity might work and so forth
and so on and electricity and all of
these other things but at the same time
there is this remarkable font of creative
randomness from which endless forms have been and
continue to evolve and so there is fundamentally
under it all this layer of uncertainty
so i would call this the grander uncertainty of
science as opposed to our everyday uncertainty the
recognition that there may be no ultimate solution
no lasting resolution no final or complete answer
and a phrase that we should never want to use no
final solution because we know where that leads
that progress really lies in uncertainty that
immutable facts can be a an impediment to progress
i mean they're the end of the line as franklin
said they're they're a conclusion as it were
the question then is not how we become
certain but how we are able to get on so
successfully while accepting uncertainty which we
are doing in fact because science progresses from
provisional belief to provisional belief
from something we know is not the whole story
but we'll get a little closer and we'll get
a little closer and we'll continue to do that
and so we have this notion then that i'll come
back to in a moment of navigable uncertainty
our ability to navigate uncertainty i'll come
back to that in a moment but it's important to
recognize in this regard that unsettled science
which is science as far as i'm concerned there's
no such thing as a settled science but unsettled
science is not unsound science and in science
revision is a victory and an essential and it
will unexpected it will always be so we have
ignorance we have failure we have uncertainty
how then will this lead to the optimistical
i have six minutes to tell you that okay let's
hope for the best so let's look at navigable
uncertainty in this idea and i'm going to use
an idea that i'm borrowing from a woman named
emma cocker who's a artist and writer in the uk
who wrote a wonderful little book of aphorisms
called the yes of the no and she uses this image
of the helmsman the helmsman steers against the
uncertain pressures of the water in the wind using
his capacity to harness the momentum of forces
that are in the end outside of our control but
this is the notion of using the uncertainty of
wind and of water which we know are very hard to
predict what they'll do and yet we can somehow
or another navigate to shore we can navigate
along these otherwise uncontrollable forces
we do this i think or can do this i guess best
by adopting what i would call a more
pluralistic stance towards science
in particular i would suggest or i would
like to see us adopt what i would call value
pluralism which was a phrase that was i think at
least sort of invented or at least popularized
by the philosopher historian isaiah berlin
which he talked about value pluralism using uh a
short little book that he wrote that had become
sort of famous he wrote many many things about
this but there's one particular book called the
hedgehog and the fox which was a critique of
tolstoy actually an analysis of tulsa and it's
based on this line from a greek poem that the fox
knows many things but the hedgehog knows one big
thing and what we want to do is be somewhere in
between the fox and the hedgehog we want we want
to know a lot of little things but we want to have
some some big solid things that we can rely on
as well so the notion of value pluralism is not
relativism not anything goes but rather we have to
choose we have but but more than one thing can go
so many chosen things can go as many as
we can afford but with the recognition
that some of these things will have opposing
even in berlin's word incommensurable values
so berlin was mostly interested in politics
and ethics and morality and humanities really
but but an example from that from berlin i
suppose would be the incommensurability of say
um liberty and security or privacy and security
where we think both are good values both are
important values but they can't always be
practiced together successfully so berlin didn't
have much interest in science in general what
interest he had was fairly critical he believed
it was robbing the humanities in many ways of
of a sort of epistemological stance but that's
to our benefit because now i think we can apply
berlin's ideas to science in ways that he might
not have thought of because he was of a period
when science was sort of supreme if you will
so and that kind of pluralism can
be reflected to some extent in in a
quote that i love by niels bohr just about as
enigmatic as stein and beckett so boer said
the opposite of a fact is a falsehood but
the opposite of a profound truth is often
another profound truth which i don't really
understand but but you know what he means so
so and i think this is quite possible that we can
have truths that are incommensurable in science
and that we can pursue multiple pathways you
know if you have a lost camper that camper is
yes fundamentally in one location but the way to
find that lost camper is to fan out to send people
out in many directions so yes most of those people
will be unsuccessful but the camper will be found
because we take this pluralistic view charles
purse a great american philosopher of the early
19th and uh or the late 19th and early 20th
century was not only a philosopher a logician
but also a working scientist compared science
not to a chain which is only as strong as the
so-called weakest link but rather like a cable
made up of many delicate strands each one fragile
but when bundled together of immense strength and
the loss of a few of those strands does not in any
way weaken the overall strength of the cable so
this is this pluralistic idea of science i'll give
you one sort of example of it that's a favorite of
mine that i've borrowed from uh colleague hassak
chang who's a professor of philosophy and history
of science at the university of cambridge he talks
about the way multiple in this case technologies
but i would even say multiple ideas in science
multiple kinds of science can coexist it uses
as an example the gps device which we all have
we're all carrying one with us right but so in
order to get this thing to work we had to launch
a satellite into orbit using basic newtonian
mechanics but on board that satellite for accuracy
is an atomic clock which is based on quantum
mechanics and then of course because it's in a
low gravity orbit there has to be a relativistic
correction so we have these three branches of
science that have many incommensurables between
them all in the service of broadcasting back to
us a map of a flat earth remarkable right
four kinds of physics all together so
so that's pluralism so as is often the case i'll
sort of more or less end this or come close to
ending this with a fable because of a parallel
because this is often the way to best understand
things so this is the parable of my dog um that is
my dog in fact by the way but that's not what the
story is about he's an old newfoundland named
orson so the story of my dog is about a young
seventh grader named tom who in order to fulfill
an assignment writes an essay called my dog
he adds the essay in and the day later the teacher
comes back to him and says tom your essay on my
dog is exactly the same as your brother's did
you copy it tom says no ma'am it's the same dog
right so we recognize that that that can't be
right right it's the same dog but it's not there's
no reason that so there are many ways to describe
this dog and why don't we explore those many ways
so so i think the question for us now about
uncertainty and optimistical beliefs is um
and and at the root i think it's not the only
thing but but much of what's at the root of
the current suspicion and distrust of science is
that we are we remain our educational system and
our public persona or the way we face the public
the press and so forth is mired in a kind of 19th
century determinism we have not yet figured out
how to talk about uncertainty in a sensible way
it's not trivial to do i think but we haven't
figured out how to teach it or talk about it
and so unless you you know go on to graduate
school um passing organic chemistry and probably
you'll never learn about uncertainty you'll never
learn that that that what you know doesn't matter
it's the questions you ask that matter you'll
never get that and so we graduate people all
the way up through university level believing
that science is right and wrong i mean i took
tests right i took a test it was a yes and
a no answer it was a right and wrong answer
i got a score what are you telling me
now you're uncertain about this or that
that ignorance and failure are important to
science so we have to figure out a way to
transition i think from teaching clockworks and
clockmaking to teaching a kind of helmsmanship
but i have answers to these questions i will come
back and give another talk which you can think
about them too for a while so let me end with
uh with just these three thoughts which which i
put up because of a phrase that i learned a while
ago from vladimir nabokov who said that the most
successful strategy is to have the imagination
of a scientist and the precision of a poet so
i'm going to use three poets and their precision
to talk to leave you with three last thoughts
e comings on ignorance whoops sorry oh no oh no
now okay e cummings on ignorance who says always
the beautiful answer who asks a more beautiful
question and on failure rita dove a former
u.s poet laureate who says about failure it is a
favor to the future and finally about uncertainty
the haiku poet basho who says too much missed
can't see fuji makes it more interesting
i have to admit that that last one i i still
borrowed from david krakauer our host tonight
and the leader of a visionary group of
people whose job it is they believe to
look at uncertainty and complexity in
this world and help us through that so
with that i i would like to thank
you all very very much thank you
thank you that's very kind thank you thank you
i'm talking okay so if anyone has a question for
stewart please raise your hand and my colleague
and i will come and bring you a microphone
so you're here in the middle
no difficult questions please
um first i just want to say thank you for such
an interesting talk and as you were talking
i happen to have the misfortune
to work in public health
and i was thinking a lot about the covid crisis
and the mess it and how i think the covet how
the messaging around kovid did everything wrong
in terms of what you've presented like tried to
present definitive information about do this don't
do that when the truth is we don't we didn't know
anything about the disease and how we should be
behaving in the face of it and it was not possible
that we knew anything because it's a brand new
thing that we have a lot of questions about
we're still learning and i'm curious if you have
any thoughts about that process of like the cdc
um the process of well the cdc was in a situation
where they were you know having to say do this and
then they had to correct and now they're you know
a lot of people are like oh the cdc doesn't know
[__] because they yeah they said this and
then they said this and they're liars and so
i'm curious if you have any thoughts about that
well so yes so i mean there will be a lot to
learn from this pandemic and we'll learn about
it over many many years i'm sure there will be
many books there's one i could recommend to
you from the santa fe institute right now i
think you pick it up on the table well actually
you can't pick it up because it's really big but
um but you can buy it at the table out there
and maybe get somebody to pick it up for you
you'll get a hernia otherwise so i think there are
many things about all of this that we will learn
from this pandemic and and at some point we will
think of it maybe even as a blessing in disguise
we will begin to understand that certainty will
not work in in in some cases that we need to
recognize uncertainty there's a famous um i don't
know how famous it is but there's a fun uh um
anecdote about harry truman not so many fun
anecdotes about harry truman i suspect but
but he was one of the first presidents to have a
science advisor as a almost cabinet-level person
and at some point i guess he was he was said to
have yelled out in exasperation could somebody
please find me a one-handed scientist because he
was tired of getting all this information at the
end of which the guy would say on the other hand
could be this right but but you know two hands are
better than one right so that's the way it is and
i think we'll learn from this that that there's
no sense in getting certain advice when it's on
when it's based on fundamental uncertainty i'll
also point out that there's a lesson in pluralism
you know we're quite lucky that we managed to have
these mrna vaccines because we almost lost that
whole technology because it wasn't funded for many
years it wasn't believed to be probably wouldn't
be about i mean we knew how to make vaccines right
we know from jenner and pasteur and salk and all
those characters we've been making vaccines for
years that's the way we do vaccines we don't want
to hear about mrna and so those people existed in
a wilderness in the desert as it were for years
keeping the technology alive and it turns out to
have been incredibly successful and much faster
than we would have been able to make a vaccine
any other way and so that's why pluralism
is so important because you know we had that
going at least a little bit um there are many many
examples of that in science and i hope we'll learn
these things from this pandemic we should learn
something look at the very least you know the
1918 flu pandemic killed over 50 million people so
it's terrible that 5 million people have died from
covid but it's not 50 million and that's a lower
estimate so imagine even if this had happened 25
or 30 years ago how much worse it would have been
then so we do make progress we have to recognize
that as well i think but the uncertainty part
of it is an important lesson for us to learn
which i hope our political leaders leaders
will learn but also educationally it's a way
to teach this lesson i'm sorry i went on too
long about that is there another question yeah
oh okay there's been um number one
thank you is a fantastic lecture and um
my question is about who gets to ask the
questions and there's there's new emphasis
in this administration on equity and inclusion in
the scientific field and trying to ensure there's
more justice and fairness in who gets to ask
the questions and whose questions are considered
important and i'm just kind of curious about
where that fits in with this kind of framework
of ignorance failure uncertainty and optimism
and seeking you know really great questions so um
so this simple answer to a very
complicated question is that i would i
consider diversity issues and things like that
in science to be part of pluralism so i see that
as a pluralistic approach not just in terms of
what experiments we do or what kinds of science
we support but what kinds of scientists we support
and what kinds of ideas come into science because
we can be pluralistic or diverse if you will and
inclusive and so i i just i can't see any reason
not to do that i don't really know why we didn't
do it for so long i mean it's just it's one of
those ridiculous puzzles i mean you know it should
be obvious that that there's no reason to exclude
at least half the population and in many ways more
than half the population um from the practice of
science uh or the practice of anything for that
matter i suppose but so i think these are very
important initiatives and i think they will have
a significant effect on science um there's a
woman named helen longino who's been a um he's a
philosopher of science who's been an advocate of
pluralism and science for years and she's also
now as takes pluralism as a feminist cause and
she's absolutely right that that bringing
new ideas into science is crucial you know
i mean i know i'm an old white guy but but and
i know and it you know it's true that science
started with a bunch of old white actually they
weren't that old because nobody lived that long
but but they were white guys that's true and
um and they were old for their day i suppose
but um but that doesn't mean that's the way it
has to be i mean there's nothing special about
that nothing special about them being europeans i
mean science is now a global practice and and has
benefited from being a global practice in every
way that i can imagine i don't see any way that
it's been hurt by being a more global practice
and i can't imagine it being hurt by being
by being done more by by a more diverse group
of people so is that that answer your question
or did you did you have something more that i said
a little bit of it i you know it's a big question
but but it's something we should all support and
and i think for the most part it is supported
i mean it's always hard to tell whether people
are really behind this or not really behind it
you all know the symphony orchestra story with
diversity i'm going to give you an example of
how difficult the problem is because we shouldn't
trivialize it so symphony or existed in the 1980s
the symphony orchestras recognized that they had a
serious gender imbalance 90 of symphony orchestra
musicians were men and so they went on a five-year
program to try and correct this and five years
later 90 percent of symphony players were men the
claim being that we're just hiring the best people
honestly we're just hiring those people well
today all auditions for symphony orchestras and
since then are conducted behind the black curtain
and the auditionee wears soft shoes so you can't
tell what sort of step they have and all the rest
of that and now if you go to the symphony you see
about 50 50 of the players are in fact women so
even people of good intention and who recognize
bias sometimes can't help themselves it's a
difficult difficult question stuart here yeah
if you had to teach 10th grade physics
what would your classroom look like
well i don't know anything about physics
so i'm not really sure um yeah that's a
that's a very good question i mean i don't the
education question is very difficult and really
if i had answers for it i would have told you
here's here's what i think about the problem
with education i think a hundred years ago
john dewey pretty much told us everything
we needed to know about how to reform our
educational system maybe we could modernize
a few things so the question in my mind is what's
the what's the obstacle to doing that what's been
in the way of actually making these reforms
and i think what's in the way is evaluation
how we evaluate and assess both students and
teachers and the process so we're sort of stuck
with these relatively old mechanisms of evaluation
you know tests and things like that what i call
the bulimic model of education you know where
we cram a lot of crap down their throat and then
they puke it up on an exam and move on to the next
unit with no appreciable gain whatsoever you know
but but they score well and then they go to
college and they you know you continue this
on so i think the problem is is in evaluation
and assessment and that's not a trivial problem
but the one good thing i can say about it
is that i think it's a scientific problem
i think it's a soluble problem that if you put
together computer scientists education people uh
artists business people who know how to value
companies and things like that i mean there are
many ways of coming to valuations farmers who
have to make a decision as to whether to keep
that tree or pull it out because it's going to
give them apples or not there are all kinds of
processes like this and i think we need to kind of
find ways to include them and find different ways
of because that's what's standing in the way until
we figure out another way to evaluate and assess
besides testing then we can't really change
the curriculum it drives the curriculum
that's not really the answer you wanted
but that's the best i have at the moment
thank you again for the lecture it's been
fascinating and very stimulating i have a couple
burning questions i'll just choose one of them
around climate change and the ecological crisis
so part of what i see as driving some of the
inaction around this issue is that it's gradual
it's hard to define and it's indefinite and
i'm curious how you would apply some of these
principles you brought forth tonight to this
issue and any recommendations you would have for
our species and how to deal with this holistically
so so again you know again if i if i had the
answer to that well i wouldn't tell you guys
i'd sell it somewhere if i had the answer
i would tell you really um so i clearly don't
have the answer and and i'm going to say something
that my wife insisted that i'd not say tonight
because she hates it every time i say this but
it's an example that i sort of use about this so i
blame a great deal of climate change on jane fonda
and michael douglas now i know that
sounds terrible because they're
liberals and they're lefties and all the rest of
that and i know they campaign for climate change
but you know they made this movie called the china
syndrome and the movie you know there's no such
thing as a china syndrome it's a total fiction
right about a nuclear reactor that goes crazy out
of control and it burns its way through the earth
all the way through the earth and comes out in
china on the other side i mean this can't happen
all right but it stopped the nuclear industry
in its tracks granted there was three mile
island at around the same time and chernobyl
had been before that and so none of those
things helped but you know chernobyl is an
issue of its own but three mile island in the end
nobody died right i mean it was dangerous and it
was a problem but but nobody died um you know
we have i know there are all these issues about
where to store nuclear energy and nuclear waste
and all that but you know carbon has waste too
and we're storing it in the atmosphere
that's much worse than storing it you know
in the desert somewhere even though we're
in the desert i know all right it's probably
probably a sensitive issue here okay so i don't
care you can store it in a subway if you want
whatever you want to do it's still better than
parking it in the atmosphere my point i suppose
is that i think unfortunately nuclear energy
was just stopped in its track and we now have a
nuclear industry such as it is in tatters using a
technology that's 60 years old what what advances
would we have had in those 60 years i mean things
happen rapidly these days nuclear energy could
have been a solution to many things maybe not the
the only solution but you can imagine that there
might have been many many ways in which it would
be useful and and the war in ukraine is another
example of it so germany is stuck now because
they decommissioned all their nuclear reactors
and so instead of a pluralistic approach to energy
they have a singular approach gas that's it and we
have to reconcile ourselves i think to the fact
that carbon is unfortunately like a really good
source of energy it sits around inert for billions
of years or millions of years at least anyway
it's really safe nothing happens to it
until you strike a match to it and then
kaboom you get like lots of energy out of it so so
it's going to be hard to replace it and so i think
we have to think hard about many many different
ways to replace it i use the nuclear thing as an
example it's not certainly not the only way
and investing in all these other ways but i
don't think we're ever going to get off of carbon
entirely so we have to come face to face with that
my personal feeling is carbon sequestration is
the way to go and and i think that in general um
if you give people a reasonable set of solutions
they believe there's a problem it's just a
question of what you're going to do to solve that
problem and what you're willing to put up with
so one of the more remarkable things that happened
during the pandemic was that because in the
beginning of it virtually all activity stopped
i mean no airplanes there were very few cars on
the road and everybody noticed how quickly the
air cleared up right wow the air is really clean
it's really nice this is great so you can clean
it up you can do that but look at the price that
got paid i mean there were many people out of work
suffering greatly from economics and other things
child care all kinds of things that that also
resulted from not using carbon so we're sort
of stuck with it a little bit but i think again a
pluralistic approach is at least one strategy for
this and including as many kinds of energy as we
can and not stopping research prematurely in these
areas so i forgive jane and michael in the end but
but i think that's a problem we should all face
um what uh in science today shifting our
focus a little is the status of the law
of non-contradiction i'm sorry i didn't quite
get that okay in in science today what is the
status of the law of non-contradiction i don't
know what the law of non-contradiction is i mean
i could imagine okay i i guess i was i'm just
trying to sorry refocus yeah a little bit on
uh under philosophy because the uncertainty at
least as it's been talked about in connection with
some of the great physicists of the 20th century
has been the idea that there is a kind of you know
that existence in a fundamental sense is uncertain
and i think that's kind of what you're saying and
the law of non-trans addiction just simply
says there are no contradictions and is is
the uncertainty as embraced by you embracing
contradictions this is a philosophical question
pertaining to theory of knowledge epistemology
is it embracing uh contradictions or or you know
not embracing them i i would my quick answer to
this is yes it embraces contradictions and i think
that's to some extent in line with with um with
some of the thinking of somebody like like isaiah
berlin who who did not believe in i don't think
he called it the law of non-contradiction but
he believed that contradictory things exist and
that they they should be embraced that there's no
reason to deny them or to believe that any one of
them is better than another just because you have
the bigger army or something like that right you
know um and the contradictory things will go on
and there's that's the human condition and that
we might as well come face to face with that and
then make the choices that we can make there will
be hard choices to make and and we'll make them
um and that's kind of in my sense an
optimistic view of things or an optimistical
view of things since i invented a word i
better use it um nobody else will so i'm sure
um so i would say that contradictions are part
of uncertainty and they're they're part of the
condition that we find ourselves in and that
coming face-to-face with that is a good idea
embracing it is a good idea but i'll look
into the law of non-contradiction that sounds
dangerous i have to say i can't imagine
how you can make that work i mean just
just in the decisions i make every day i
can't make that work sorry yes hi over here
this is really fascinating and i'm wondering where
the concept of curiosity would fall within these
four things um what made me think of that was
your discussion about the dewey john dewey system
and education hasn't really changed very much
since then and something else i'm noticing that
there's a serious lack of curiosity amongst all
of us and i'm just wondering if this is a factor
of ignorance failure uncertainty and not being
optimistical so how would you what would you say
about that yeah so um i i have colleagues you know
i'm i mean my day job actually is a neuroscientist
right i mean i work on the olfactory system which
is believe it or not part of the brain and and so
we um so i think a lot about the brain i have many
colleagues who are neuroscientists and many people
in my department some of whom recently started
working on curiosity and this notion of what it is
and where it comes from and all the rest of that
and so there are lots of ideas about it the thing
that most impresses me honestly about curiosity
is how easily satiable it is which i think is
a disaster so people will say yeah i wonder how
that and you tell them some cockamamie story and
they go oh okay and off they go right and then and
they're not curious anymore so so i think that's a
that's a big problem i agree with you curiosity is
surprisingly satiable we we pride ourselves
on this idea of being this curious animal
that science is about curiosity that art is about
curiosity that philosophy is about curiosity and
wanting to know things but actually i'd say we're
really easily sated by by almost nothing and then
we just go on about our business so i find that
one of the more curious things about curiosity
to tell you the truth and troubling in many ways
so that's something you can develop in children
maybe and keep it going children are great at
curiosity but where does that go where does it go
yeah oh thank you for your talk it's been
really fascinating i keep coming closer to
the people that are talking about the speakers
are like everywhere but you're in the physical
world like all of us i want to note that all
the questions have been from female voices
i'm sort of interested is that true really oh cool
yeah just something i learned to there was one
guy that was one person of unknown oh there i'm
sorry yeah sorry dude but that's nice thank you i
feel good about that did i offend everybody is
that how that happened i'm old enough that i i
lived through like women just didn't [__] talk
so okay um my question is about you know this
idea of uncertainty and pluralism i'm on board
it's wonderful and i wonder i mean there are
powerful forces especially in this country but
globally want certainty they want the one right
answer and everybody subscribes to it whether they
want to or not do you think um scientists should
be more political should be out there
advocating for things or just taking a stand
so i don't want to tell any particular
scientists what to do whether they should be more
political whether they should be
taking a stand whether they should be
spending more time communicating with the public
i mean i know a lot of scientists and they're very
different people just like all the rest of us
are very different people just because we call
them all scientists doesn't really do justice
to the category in a way for anything else
some of them are very good at talking to the
public and some of them would be just dreadful
at it and i'd rather they didn't do it you
know because not going to help at all um
some of them understand and know politics quite
well and others just don't get it or don't care
about it and you know their contribution is
elsewhere so what i think is that scientists
should contribute like every other citizen
should contribute in every way they possibly can
there's no question that science is an important
part of our society and it's important part of
our politics and to leave it out i mean i think
it's an outrage that we have an entire parliament
as it were a senate and a house and i don't
think there's but one scientist among the group
i mean that doesn't make any sense to me you know
um because we live in a technological society
we're beholden to a great deal of science we ought
to think carefully about how to govern it and how
it governs our lives and it's you know it's not
the only game in town i i fond of pointing out
to people that science is actually kind of
the new kid on the block i mean human beings
have come up with many systems for organizing
knowledge and setting policies and behavior
so i mean there's you know religion and philosophy
and art and economics and law and all of those
things predate science science is the new
kid on the block it's been here 400 years
everything else has been here like for millennia
so it's still a new it's still a new toy in a way
and i think we're still trying to figure out how
it's going to work but you know it's a dangerous
toy in the wrong hands so yes i the answer
is yes we should be involved in politics but
but not everybody necessarily i'd like to see more
scientists involved in politics one of the things
that i try and tell graduate students these days
because there's always this sorry i'm maybe making
too long an answer here but i'll make it quick
you know we have this thing where on the one
hand we don't have enough scientists we have to
increase stem education and all this other stuff
on the other hand there aren't enough jobs for
the phds that we're making so who knows what
the real answer to that is but i like to tell
graduate students at columbia and elsewhere
that becoming you know becoming me is not your
only alternative becoming a faculty member at a
university running a laboratory getting grant
the whole mish booker there is not your only
alternative you could become a journalist you
could become a science communicator you could
become a politician you could become a legislator
you could become a business executive you could
become any one of a number of of things in which
your scientific background will be very useful
more than 50 of the people we graduate from
law school has never practiced law but law is
considered a good education for doing many other
things because it teaches you to read critically
to think critically to write but science does the
same thing much of the time that we spend is not
in the laboratory pouring crap from one thing to
another you know most of the time i spend writing
grants and reading papers and trying to think
through things critically and those are abilities
and talents that we train in our graduate students
that would be very useful in many other spheres so
i think that's also an opportunity that that
we shouldn't miss that training scientists
is a good idea because they don't have to
go into science and work in a laboratory
they can they can have an effect on society
in many many many useful and important ways
well on that very optimistical note
can we have one last thank you for
the round of applause for stuart firesteen our new
you